Most interesting part of the evening the
question and answer session we have three
mics two for the brothers one in the front is
to my left one in the back is on to
my left and one in the right for the
sisters please give your name and your
profession the preference of order will be for
non muslims first one question at time if anybody has to ask
the second question they have
to get back to the question and come again now
I start on to my front left the first
question will be for the non muslim
brothers first will be the mic on to my
left the
second back is on to my left and third is
for the sister so we come in the clockwise
direction yes brother first give your name
and your profession my name is Krishna Rao
I am working as general manager abroad finally today
one of my first am come here with one of
my friend who but me here today in fact
doctor Zakir am seen mum on TV  And always
I had this great party that God gave me to see
him personally and ask why many loves I had doubt
in my
life when God created one religion and he did not
make one religion for everyone so that peace would have been
prevalent on this earth he knew it
and he never knew about it so these are the
problems which are going to be faced very good question very important question why does not God
create only one religion why did he
create all the different religions so there will be no
confusion no fighting and all agreeing it is very good
question
and in Quran Allah Seeran Inra Imran chapar
number 19
Islam is acceptable in say ala ilam
Islam means submitting to God so if you read the
religion the mighty God only saint messenger
to preach one religion the messenger came right from
Adam peace be upon your right  Do not know
Jesus Muhammad Peace be upon him the prophet a
blood prophet said the
messenger who faces the
error no tribe needs
Allah and every people have the messenger came
behind they told nothing but submitting they will to
mighty God and the basic message that the
messenger told oneness of God he did not beg him
no mother no father he has one they nothing like
him but due to times l what the
messengers
preach it corrupted and if you had my talk i mention that most of
the scripture came
before the Quran they got change
and Allah says in the Quran in all places if he
wanted he could have made everyone submit to God everyone is a Muslim
brother don't
take reason the real meaning of Islam is it and its way of
life submitting to God
and Muslim don mean a person the name is Zakir
Abdullah Sultan Muslim mean a  Person Who
Submits His Will to God If You Submit Your Will to God
in Arabic I'll Call You a Muslim So Don't Go
on the Labels Given Sultan Zakar
Abdullah Muslim in Arabic Means a
Person Who Submits His Will to God Any One Who
Submits the Will to God He is Called as a
Muslim So All the Messengers That Came They That We Have
to Submit a Will to God All of Them They Are
Monotheism All They Are Tawhid But by the
Passage of Time All the Scriptures Kept on
Changing and That is the Reason Almighty God He
Sent the Last and Final Messenger Prophet
Muhammad Peace Be Upon Him and the Last and
Final Revelation in the Quran Now the Messenger That Came
Before Prophet Muhammad Peace Be Upon Him the
Revelation That Came Before the Quran He Only
Mentioned for Two People and for All Time by Name
for Mentioned in the Quran Ra Zabur Ejeel and
Quran Torah and the Wahi the Revelation Given to Moses
Peace Be  Zabur is the Wahi, the lesson given to
David, peace be upon him, Gospel is the Wahi, the
revelation given to Jesus, peace be upon him
and Quran is the last and final revelation given
to the last and final messenger Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon
him. Quran also says in
chapter number 13 verse number 38 it says in Quli
Azn Kitab in every age there is only one revelation
and seven revelations from down below but all the
revelation that came before the Quran and all the
messengers that came before Prophet Muhammad were only
for those people and for that
time that the reason almighty God did not
fit to preserve it but since Quran is a
last and final revelation not only
for the Muslims of the Arabs it is only for the
whole of Huti and Prophet Muhammad is not only
for the Muslim Arabs he has been only
for the whole of Huti that the reason he has
It has been prose in all the major scriptures
and this book the Quran Allah says in sara
Hijr chapter number 15 verse number no we have
read the Quran and we shall accept it from corruption so what we believe is the
almighty God from all messengers to
preach only one religion that is submitting
your will to almighty God in Arabic i say
Islam Jesus never came to preach the wad kriti
dst in bible or not
in the full bible the wad kriti dst the wad kriti wa
nickname given to follow Jesus and
book this
nickname Jesus must preach it gall naught
my will but my father will God will
in Arabic he preach nothing but
Islam similarly if in Bhagavad Gita Shri Krishna
said that you have to submit a will to God if in
Arabic he says that you have to accept
ilam what we believe is that all the messengers
t  Nothing but submitting your will to God that is the
reason the Quran says in Sura Imran Chapter 3
Number 19 Ina in dala Islam
only way of life accepted in the sight of
God is submitting to mighty God you have to go back to the
reason scripture go back to
commandment almighty God and submit your will
commandment of God and then you will be following the path his
second question is to my left the mic
behind good evening Zakir Naik my name is
Naresh completed my become a looking for a
profession in film industry well my
first question to you is about human
evolution what does the Quran say about the
human evolution because a common man in a
common sense thinks that Adam and Wah were the
first person I mean the cause of human
evolution so if you look into that sense now
for Adam and Wah only is our great great great great
father I can say so  And we are
like sons and daughters to him so how do we relate
for us individually to our own brothers
and
sisters so what Quran speaks about how we came from one common great grand
parent Adam and Eve taking into account how we evolved from creation I am a
medical doctor I pass my
maths then you can say how we evolved from creation if you start
thinking of Darwin then that we have been
evolved from apes if that is a
question you can refer to my video
cassette Quran modern science is given in detail that that has been proved to be
Darwin
series but main question is that if we have
common great grand parents Adam and
Eve how come we are marrying our own cousins ​​is the question
correct it is not related with
monkeys no it is not related with monkeys question
you can refer to my Quran modern
science Allah says in the Quran in Sir Hujrat
chapter no  49 verse number 13
cut off single pair of male and
female not cut off single pair of male and female a
divide in this nation so much
taqwa and good consciousness coming to question if we have got one common great great great great great
parents so how come we are marrying our cousins
today science tells us that if you marry your
immediate blood brother and sister there are high
chances of genetic problem there for in
Islam and most of the religious people marrying your
immediate blood brother and sister it is
prohibited and marrying your immediate blood
relation as Quran says sara nisa chapter number
for verse number 223 2 it is said your not to marry your
mother or allow your aunt or aunt or aunt not to marry your sister and all
goes to the same
blood line this is prohibited in Quran and
prohibited in most of the
religions now as f  Among second cousins ​​and the first
cousins, Islam does not prohibit fourth cousins.
Most of the relatives are related to each other. But some relatives are related to each other. First cousins ​​are related to each other. There is a
high chance of genetic
problem in keeping with decreasing blood relations. If you keep decreasing blood relations,
in the first cousin the chances are negligible but there is a chance of second cousin. There is no
problem at all. If you marry an
unknown or non-relative out
of the blue, there can be a genetic problem that is
unique but can take place only based on that.
In this verse of the Quran it is said that Adam and Eve have
common great grandparents, then we are called brothers
in marriage or you are not brothers in marriage. If
marrying
brothers in
marriage is not a problem, then there is no problem if I agree with
you. All the human beings they may be
your cousins, may be third, fourth, fifth, tenth
100 thousand million what ever it is i agree
with you we are one big family but there is no
restriction in marrying them and even
scientifically it is permitted only marrying
your immediate family members blood brother and
paternal aunt maternal aunt there are high
chances of genetic problems
but the other alternative so i do agree with you we are
all humans being a brother in law there is no
problem in marrying them islam does not
prohibit and in side does not prohibit hope an answer yes
the next question goes to the
sister side on to my right yes sisters
my name is peace my friend Abdul brought me here actually i never
expected a
mass so you know why and then i been in
conversation this friend Abdul is the same
clear few doubts but coming here after
specially hearing you i am up to
the truth of
islam but yes you  Given the name
Peace is in the world so much strife going
on
and well there is something called nothing that you need to
address lam from lam di a
nose a ma
speech and set now pass through out the world the
world at large
sister if you really appreciate the talk
and really impress the matter that is spoken and suggest that
I would request you to
accept this religion of submitting a will to
God and if you accept submit will to God then this is
the time you can get true peace ilaam kamm
root salam me peace it rabbi
wad film ch mes u
submit will to God so the
best way you can get peace is by
submitting to lam from God so first of all I will come
to the rest of the world I am first
interested in ya sister directly by the
queen fuss I like you to be total
peace so my request is you accept the
life of submitting to almighty God  And be at
peace I would be very happy
sister as far as telling the world at large about peace this
is an exhibition a
conference peace the vision of Islam we have such
exhibition and this is the fourth such
exhibition we had a similar one in Bombay a
couple of months back from the 23rd of November to the 23rd
of December in Bombay and the audience
you see on the last day was multiple times more
200000 so if this impresses you may be 10
15000 that was 20 times more in
Bombay more than 200000 for the last talk of mine
the topic was peace
the solution for Huti and Islam the solution
Huti and I do agree with you that the small
number 10000 15000
Bombay is a very small number we should proclaim
it to the world at large  Region two
years back we have started a channel by the
name of Peace
TV and this Peace TV Al Hamdulillah in the
past two years at present it reaches all over
the world in the countries in Asia Middle
East Africa Australia Europe North
America Al Hamdulillah and today it has reached most
of the world they can watch if they want to watch but the
people who are watching are 75 million it is
the largest watching Islamic channel in the world
percentage wise little bit more than 75 million of
human population so at least I can bear
witness to the mighty God on the day of judgement so we at least give
the message to 75 million of the human
population we pray
Allah Subhan Taala
the viewership
increased but those who want to watch you only have to put a dish me by of
6000 less than
$200 and almost any part of the world
you can watch this channel so  We are also
conveying this message of peace Islam through
out the world but now I am interested
sister that hope you accept this message of peace yes
thank
you yes question from this
brother not to my left I am
Nand Gopal I am
journalist my question is disappointing the
striking similarity of the concept of
God in most of the religions there is absolute
no compassion and increase intolerance between religions how do
you think this can be stopped it is easy to tell
to the world because we don't were in
the world but you can tell us from the
point how it can be stopped at individual
level
team bavi wa iter din
basic r it the
people r ris leader they under na go buk
scripture but only reason they want to hold the
flock together
and they don't want the mass to read
Scripture but the mass to read the ridge
Scripture and follow the scripture
directly who will go to them best they go back
to scripture understand the
scripture and follow it what we believe in we know very well that the
major reasons they say God one God has no images as worship to us we
fight
most of the major reasons beside this they give in
idol worship because for example if you ask
Hindu priest whether Vedas are absolutely
crystal clear the God has no image he
will tell me yes doctor nayak i know it is
absolutely clear but comes
God has no images it is for the people of higher castes
the people of lower castes they require idol
to consent i said we should read scripture no note in our
philosophy so our leaders they bring the
philosophy and set idol as use for
concentration i do agree with you they tell me
doctor nayak the Vedas idol worship the Vedas  Almaty
God having images but it is for people of higher
consciousness so I tell the priest, Swami ji
we Muslims have ladies who do the higher knowledge but
images are required in this way
most of the religious leaders and the priest and
the Pandit of most of the communities what they do is same way I
prove my religious beliefs above all I never believe that you believe in
Jesus Christ and you
believe in Him that is the reason I tell the
Hindus go back to your Vedas I
tell the Christians go back to your
scriptures I know there are differences brother I am not saying that there are
no differences in the
religion I can give a langar talk on the
differences between Islam Hinduism and
Christianity but what do I say to all the
human beings at least believe that one
scripture is 100% the word of God no
most  Of the human beings won't have a
problem accepting that Hindu will say I have
no problem accepting Vedas to be the
word of God The Christian will say I have no
problem accepting Bible to be 100% the
word of God The Muslim will say I have no
problem accepting the Quran to be the word then I tell at
least let us follow what is
common in the scripture what is different we will
discuss it to you let us agree
to follow what is common and
in my species I try and get the quality
and I prove that all the major scripture whether it be
Hinduism Christianity Judgment Scripture Islam All of them say there is only one God he has got no images he cannot begin to have no
parents let's worship this one God
the major scripture Judaism Christianity Hinduism
Buddhism Parsham they say there is
a messenger to come His  Name is
Prophet Mohammad Peace Be Upon Him I can give a
talk on Muhammad Salam in the Hindu
Scripture I can give a talk on Muhammad
Salam in the Major World Religions so I say at least there is
one God who is not begun has got no
image has got no idol
second point from all the Major Scriptures there is
a messenger to come and this final messenger
his name is Prophet Mohammad it is mentioned in
the Bible in the Gospel of John chapter number
16 verse number 12 to 14 Jesus said peace be upon him I have many
things to say to you but he
cannot bare them now for he the spirit
of thee shall come he shall guide you to all that he shall not speak of himself all that he shall speak he shall
glorify me New Testament
Talking about Prophet Mohammad Peace Be Upon Him
Old Testament Book  Gospel of John Chapter
Number 14 Verse Number 16 Gospel
of John Chapter
Number 15 Verse Number 26 Gospel of John Chapter Number 16 Verse Number 17 Gospel of John Chapter Number 16 Verse Number 18 to 19 Speaks About the Coming of Muhammad Sallam in
the Book of Dutton Chapter Number 18 Verse Number
19 Speaks About the Coming of Muhammad Sallam in the Book of Ayah Chapter Number 29 Verse Number 12
Speaks About the Coming of Prophet Muhammad Peace Be Upon Him
in the Book of Ayah Chapter Number 29 Verse Number 12 Speaks About the Coming of Prophet Muhammad Peace Be Upon Him in the New Testament Gospel of John Chapter Number 14 Verse Number 16 Gospel of John Chapter Number
15 Verse Number 26
Gospel of John Chapter Number 16 Verse Number 18 Gospel of John
Chapter Number 16 Verse Number 12 to 14 All the
Speaks About the Coming of Muhammad
Sallam I Can Only Give References If You Read
The Hindu Scripture Bhavishya Purana
Parva Three Khand Three  Chapter
Three Verse 5 to 8 Bhavishya Purana Parvathi Khand
Chapter Three Verse 10 27 Speaks
about Prophet Mohammad Peace be upon him He also
speaks about Prophet Sallam Rig Speaks
now love came to him
and in the Kalki Purana it
speaks about Kalki came to him It is said the
name of his father will be Vinyas Me Servant
of God in Arabic Abdullah name is said the father his mother name is said the Sumati Me
Serenity come Peace
in Arabic it is said the name of the mother
of Prophet Mohammad Peace be upon him It is said the name of the
first Khalifa Rann of the 12th Rabi Awal It is said that he will be
born in a city of
Peace It is said that he will be born as the
chief of the tribe of Mecca On and on
and on Talking about no one but the last and
final Messenger  So I tell you about the
differences, let us agree on the community in
Hinduism, Christianity,
Judaism, Islam and Buddhism that there is one
God, he begets none, he has got no images,
worship none other than a false messenger, at last a false messenger came, a prophet passed away, if we agree with the
community
and our message will be proclaimed, but the people,
contractors of reason, priests of reason, they do not want to lose their faith, so they prevent the faith
to read scriptures, believe me, I do not believe, I
love, respect me, believe me, people do not want to speak about religion, I
love it and believe
me, the non-Muslims respect me, many times more than
the
Muslims, I do not follow the custom, the non-
Muslims custom, Dr. Zakir Naik, whatever he
says, he will say the truth, he will not say anything for the sake of truth, he will do that, nothing but they are
taking oath
in the coat of law, so what we believe, speak
the truth, so I do agree  With you brother the
difference of interest because of
fear they skipped and came to come and one brother thank you
doctor question my left Mike Baha my
name is Pascal a teacher my
profession Christian teacher granted to you Agnes
Gospel English of we Christians believe in this
example number one in the four
Gospels I came to know the words of the but there was a voice from heaven
saying this is my blessed son
in home I am well please listen you to him the
same way number two neither on Mount Thabor nor was
transfigured nor his face seen like the sun there was a voice from heaven saying
this is my blessed son in home I
please listen you to him several times
neither cast out the devils they came out of the
men proclaim the son of the living God they have come to torture
us before time and again
before the high priest the high priest  Ask
Him in the name of the Living God I ask
the Son of the Living God Christ says he is the Son of God
and the Priest is number five the Priest
and the Son Jesus before the Palate they say this
man says he is the Son of God just for a reason they want
to crucify me not it the very
reason they wanted to put crucifix on the
cross he claims to be the Son of God because even if he does
directly say I am the Son of God
I indirectly said suppose I say you are
Doctor Zakir Naik and your MBBS
doctor and you tell me yes brother you said it is not at all
set yourself say I am Doctor
Zakir Naik MBBS in the same way in which I am the
Son of God but I am the Son of God
again no more asked for
reference we are giving
help or else no problem to ask for the
five  thing Jesus
said yes fine come give you a reply my
challenge brother was point out a single
unequivocal statement in the complete bible by
Jesus Christ peace by Himself set
I am God and they say worship me I am ready to
accept Christianity you did not point
out a single unequivocal
statement in the complete bible by Jesus
Christ peace by Himself set I am God and they say
worship
me here in the bible this is
King James version and your teacher and you want to be a
pastor are you a pastor no no no you are a
teacher I am a teacher or a believer of
Christianity there something like red letter bible what ever
Jesus said it in red you find something
and thing can be clue to thing first used every you
correctly what you wanted to
quote was the gospel of John chapter number by
number from the word God soul of the world that he gave his
only begotten son who sowers believe in  Him shall
not die but has everlasting life it is not
in all the four Gospels it is only in the
Guspot number 16 please note it down you
can check it up Guspot 3 verse number 16 for
God gave the world that he gave his only begotten son who sower
believe in him shall not die but has
everlasting life and again you quoted in the
ending the fifth time the Jesus Christ said he was the
son of God you said that do you know the
Bible is the son of God by the ton if you read
the Bible Adam was the son of God peace be upon him ephah was the son of God
Israel was the son of
God if you read the Romans chapter number 1 it said all those were
led by the spirit of God they are sons
of God if you are a godly person you are a
son of God if I am a godly person I am a son
of God according to the Bible but they say  No no no no no
Jesus Christ is not a
normal son He is the begun son as far as the
last question son of God Bible has got
sons of God by the name Adam is the son of God
Ephraim is the son of God Israel is the son of God All they are
led by the spirit of God are sons of
God But the Christian missionary tells me no no no
Jesus Christ is not a normal son
coming to your first question He is the begun
son and then they quote you that quote me I am
helping you brother brother Gospel of John
chapter 16 number 16 for God saw the world that gave His only
begun son who shall believe in Him shall not
die but ever lasting life
brother do you know the meaning of the word
begun what is the meaning of the word
begun what is the meaning of the word begun began is
not the sense in which your human sense sees
the word begun I am asking you  The meaning
of the word begun yes I know what is the
meaning of word begun become there are two senses
no see no safe human but he himself see big me the
flesh and blood  Of him is son but not y say God but son it does
n't mean body it began him it is to see
the close association between the father and the
son it is l If you say son I say suppose someone come here
and I tell him my son he will not mine because he is a young boy I tell him the son come here he will come If I say begin son come here he may
punch me on my jaw because I had never had
sex with his mother If I tell a
small boy begin son and a young boy may be 23
years old I am a [ __ ] 40 If I say begin come punch me on my jaw it began by God it
belongs to the lower animal function of sex
and that is the reason if you read the Revised
Standard Version of the Bible revised by
two Christian scholars of the highest
eminent backed by 50 different Christian
denominations they say this word began in
Gospel of John chapter number verse number
16 is an interpolation is a conjuncture is a
fabrication and they throw it out of the Bible do you know that if
you read the Revised
Standard Version of the Bible which is the
best seller revised by the Christian
scholars of the highest eminent backed by
50 different Christian denominations they say this was begun is an
interpolation is a conjuncture
is a fabrication so the word begun has been
thrown out so if you say son God has got sons
by the ton in the Bible so coming to your
first question and the last question that is answered it is coming
to your second and third which
you mention that he does not devil ct the
full verse you have cted to me the full verse which is a
code in my talk according to the
Gospel of Matthew chapter number 12 verse
number 28 said I cast out devils with the
Spirit of God Gospel of God Chapter number
11 Verse number 20 I with the finger of God cast
out the devil it done because he alone does it he does it
with the help of God that does not mean he is God. In these
verses quoted they clearly mention that he was a
messenger of God he was God himself that is the
reason I challenge you to point
out a single unique statement in the complete
Bible that Jesus can be his own son say
I am God and he worships me and I am ready to
accept Christianity now what Jesus ever said that just if I tell him to be my own son I do not make him my own son I will
call you Doctor Zakir Naik
fine and if I do not object to doing it it may be true it may be wrong people say
Doctor Zakir Naik I do not need
to be a scholar or
consider myself to be a student  of
knowledge if people call me scholar and if I
continue that does not mean accept it they
consider me to be a scholar I don't consider myself
to be a scholar I always refer to myself as a
student of knowledge a talib ilm so what you have to
point out from
the bible
is anyway in the bible it should be red letter
red letter means the words of jesus christ
peace be upon him point out a single
statement unequivocal statement and
statement from the complete bible jesus christ peace be upon
himself said I am god and worship me I am to
accept
charity yes can I take question from non
muslim sister on to my right good evening sir sir I have got to question
for this
evening first one is what is
shariah bz we follow the quran the holy book life
style everything depends upon but what is
shariah because yesterday I saw  In BBC
punishments are given to the criminals based
on what is written in the Sharia so I want to know what is it that is
my first question the second question
is usually in
Hinduism and I have got the meditation
practice by which when we even change the
lokas we concentrate on something at least the
light
but not your
shloka the verses how do you concentrate on the
verses and get into it and speak to God this is
my second question sir sister to question first question she wants to know what is Sharia she had
on the television that is to Sharia and second question is what do you consent on when we do something can't be written in the Sharia so I want to know what is it that is my first question the second question is usually in Hinduism and I have got the meditation practice by which when we even change the lokas we
concentrate on something at least the light but not your shloka the verses how do you concentrate on the verses and get into it and speak to God this is my second question sir sister to question first question she wants to know what is Sharia she had on the television that is to Sharia and second question is what do you consent on when we do something can't be written in the Sharia the first question is Shalam
beran n se dya phalo Sharia dya phalo ai ya wir a
tan waking me  I took down the Balti God in
and prayed up what is ruling by the
Sharia so I said okay can you have alcohol
so I said the Sharia says alcohol is
prohibited I gave a reference Sara Mada
chapter number five verse number 90 so Sharia means
following the legal system of Islam based on
the Quran and the authentic sayings of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him then the second
question is concern that we should something we consent to something like
the light what do we
concentrate
on one we pray we pray to Allah subhana
ta'ala what do we do is we communicate with
Almighty God
directly prayer is the hotline to God or
hotline hotline to God directly and here what we do we
consent on the
meaning we don't concentrate on an
image but we don't believe the Almighty God has an
image the moment you do that you are biting
God now imagine when you are saying that to
concentrate on god you are making an idol
almighty god you are betting god and limiting
god to idol i suppo idol fadl be ijn god
help ld one be all god one abu gad to na
pray directly and know the
meaning n sabe and i say the best way to pray
sala is to understand the meaning and
concentrate on the meaning and then we follow our
prayer one we say pray in english to pray is to ask for
help to beseech in arabic sala does not necessarily mean to
pray sala beside asking for help we are also
thanking Allah subhana wa ta'ala thanking
almighty god and samaali getting
guidance fam
after imam
leader of this pray beside thanking god beside
asking for
help we are getting guidance don't consume alcohol don't consume alcohol don't consume alcohol don't consume
idol  Worship and in Allah we get guidance from Allah and Salah
at the reason I get Salah to be the right of
programming
and to bless
Allah and Salah you should offer Salah minimum five
times a day because the amount of evil we see around us is the amount
of evil things we see and there are
high chances we can be
programmed so that the reason we offer Salah we get guidance to reach
asanas minimum
five times a
day five times a day we are being programmed to
reach asanas so our Salah is much more
superior than just praying
for help or asking for help or thanking God and
we are getting guidance from Mighty God so we can become
the straight path and you can follow the path
of the Shariah follow the path of submission or Mighty God ho Tha Aa
Mr.
Ravindran with to
and Mr. My
friend I also noted this point of my
journal The One God of Mighty So  I have only one
question what is the miracle of in Islam son of
Solomon 51 like that
so I want to know the miracle so many religions they say miracles so I want to know
the Islam miracle
ask the question what is the miracle of Islam
and then son of Solomon
51 son of Solomon is a part of the Bible son
of Solomon is a part of the Bible
in it is describing an act
[music] there is most lord
lovely lord
and no one mentions the word
Mohammad in the language we add it as a
word of respect the word of Mohammad added Mohammad means God so I mean
respect for God so but in the translation
of the Bible they have translated the proper
noun Mohammad as love but if you
read the son of Solomon chapter 5 verse number 16
it speaks  About the Coming of the Last and
Final Messenger Prophet Muhammad Peace be upon him I even
mention my name
first question what is a miracle in
Islam there are many miracles in Islam and if you
read the sahih hadi there no lesson 300
miracles which a big prophet did but the miracle
we boast about is it is
glorious
Quran this is the miracle of Islam all the
miracles for example we believe that Moses
Peace be upon him he
gave life to the dead but he can only say can we
go back in
time and check whether Moses passed away or not
time people will not believe in you and all poets so they don't have
faith in scripture he can go back in
time to see Moses Peace be upon him and Jesus gave
life to the dead and no prophet Muhammad Peace be upon
him but he can only say can we go back in time one
miracle or one miracle  The time is today and will
beat the
Quran it is the miracle of miracles
and more week back now day back on the 12th of
January I gave the Quran and modern science kabal
and inbal and a proof the lecture this Quran is mi in li
mikal it mikal of mikal it mikal
of l
time previously or miracle it prove it then came
of lit and poetry Quran is the best
Arabic literature available n face of teaching to
Muslim non Muslim Arabic sl b day i re
scripture se in pot fashion world fat l ya bav
in its answer is no but in a of lit a post
is sa tenno bak I prove what Quran is
20 ya bak 100 ya bak 200 ya bak and this inan no one is bit lamgad
best mikal almet mikal of l ty i
gra yes n to my left mikal bak
a non muslim brother good  I am sorry sir my name
is M S Sreedharan i am bank
officer i am earning my salary from my
bank from the bank's main income is interest i have
some muslim friends who have
reservation even taking food and tea from my
home coming to my source of income is from the
main interest income of the bank please
clarify if the interest as mentioned in the
holy quran is the same that the modern bank is
practicing receiving and paying one second
my question is incomplete i am sorry and i have my
own professional difficulty now i mean
mobilizing deposits from my muslim
friends and lending loan to them also because they evolve
receipt and payment of
interest please clarify the position badar b
non muslim hi works in the bank question that why do
muslims resist come
to his house because he earning money from interest what is
interest and he
find the difficulty  Mobilizing Fund from the
Muslims Brother Dabiq Wud Mention
Riba
Riba means interest as well as interest Some people
give them money but do not include interest as well as
interest According to Quran Riba means
money earned on money
Lent and interest means absorb interest Both use
and interest both are prohibited and
the Quran mention the word Riba in
different places in Sura Imran Chapter
No. 3 Verse No. 130 In Sir Nisa Chapter No.
4 Verse No. 161 It is mentioned in Sura Baqarah
Chapter No. 1 Verse No. 275 Thrice in Sura
Baqarah Chapter No. 1 Verse No. 276 As well as
in Sura Baqarah Chapter No. 1 Verse No.
278 and 279 And just last verse Sura Baqarah
Chapter 279 Say If You Give Up Not Your
Demand of Riba of Interest Then Take  Notice
of Allah and Rasool that anyone dealing with
interest gives interest and takes
interest only if he is waging a war with mighty God
Allah and his messenger
pray it is one of the major sins in
Islam one of the major sins and one of
the lowest level of interest is illumination
with mother no what is the logic behind it you can take
on interest fee from the economy by
Quran it is but logically for me to prove to you that
interest is haram it will take money from us it is not
possible now but in this region
interest is prohibited because it makes rich
person more richer and richer person more and further more
interest there are many ills you know in
most of the banks they fund gangs they fund
alcohol by in islam we believe in profit
and l sharing today you are backer you know the
company which is the least date is better
company this interest was started by  King
Judge banking system is the main fraud previous
wader and now to make the ri people more rich if fer
person want loan from back it diff y wa to see what it is how much it is earning more diff fer
pun
to get loan and further more if y list the top
companies the top companies they are debt free company
there today we
find stock
listing you know anil ambani he floated the
la power n 1.1 lakh crore 100 times more
people who
wanted no banked haven so much money and he
floated stock what stock is in islamic
system proof sharing
current in interest it haram but negative
factor in islam believe in proof sharing your
baashy baash company if yuk profit you get
profit you make a loss it's not fixed
8% and the other person makes loss of money so
what do they do they float shares so if you buy
stock of a halal company it is halal as it is not
alcohol company it is not bank it's not
haram activity it  It is Islamic so we in
Islam believe in profit and law sharing
Anil
Ambani has floated it and got 100 times more what he
wanted correct 1.1 lakh crore
it is not possible for any
other mutual fund banker base number one
islam believe in profit sharing
interest fixed amount on money earn no
money lend is haram for more details refer to
my video cassette interest free economy
prom g ba the Quran that the reason if you change
your bank from a conventional bank to
Islamic bank insha Allah you will have
Muslim customers insha Allah and today the
Indian government the RBI the finance
minister has given permission for a true
Islamic bank but there are people approaching him I myself spoke
to chit manram he came
to Saadi Arabia and there is high
possibility Manmohan Singh the prime minister
initially or finance minister he
understands better there is high possibility insha Allah insha Allah he is
studying the system along with
the  Prime Minister Manmohan Singh
and the Finance Minister Mr. Chim there is
high possibility very soon to see Islamic
system and you may want to join Islamic
bank in the region today Citi Bank Islamic
window HSBC has Islamic window most
of the international banks have Islamic window because they find they make
more profit
and they give more profit to the clients it
is Islamic so if we follow the Sharia the
Quran and Hadith you also earn and you let
others also earn hope the answer question Badar thank
you